[Music]
the annual circus of un climate talks
has just ended here in Charnel Shake in
Egypt
I'm Catherine bayik I'm the environment
editor for The Economist and this is my
take on the outcome of Club 27.
it was truly an extraordinary night I
have been to seven I believe of these
conferences now and I've seen them
finish at all hours of the day morning
and night coming in on Saturday the hall
was completely empty
it's tumbleweeds here as you can see
most people have left
most people that is except for the
politicians who are still trying to come
to an agreement on several key points
the delegates really were very divided
on many of the issues and in the end the
Egyptians decided to run talks right the
way through the night they were just
determined to get it through in the end
there were two big wins and one
substantial loss at cop 27. the first
win was a very first acknowledgment at
this High political level that the issue
of loss and damage is here to stay and
that it requires funds to flow from
donor countries to the most vulnerable
countries to the impacts of climate
change this was a real win for poor
countries the issue of loss and damage
has been swatted away for 30 years since
the early 1990s for the most part there
has always been a sense that this was a
losing issue and so to have it
recognized at this higher political
level to have it in an official UNF
Triple C document and to have that
recognition not only the loss and damage
is here to say but that it requires
Finance flows is a big win
the second win is I think an
acknowledgment is something that's been
bubbling around in climate circles for
several years now that in order to truly
address climate change there's going to
need to be a rethink of the Global
Financial system and then finally the
big loss and this was felt most acutely
in the closing plenary was a sense that
delegates came here for what was billed
as the implementation cause they wanted
to see
a real
push for greater ambition on action on
climate change for greater ambition for
decarbonization
there was a certain amount of momentum
that was generated in Glasgow last year
an acknowledgment that the next eight
years now out to 2030 are essential to
limit global warming and people came
here hoping that they were going to be
able to build on that with with targets
with discussions about peaking carbon
dioxide emissions for instance that
didn't materialize and it was very very
clear that that was acutely felt as a
loss by many of those present in the
room in Mission speaking before 2025 as
a science tells us is necessary not in
this text clear follow-through on the
phase down of coal not in this text a
clear commitment to phase out all fossil
fuels not in this text there's a sense
here that some of the failings of this
talk some of the things that weren't
quite finalized and certainly not in the
ways that people had hoped have left
quite a lot of work to do ahead of next
year's Corp and at The Summit in Dubai
in November next year I've got to go and
see how the coffee is doing and then I'm
going to go
[Music]
to read more about cop and all things
climate please click on the link
[Music]